so it's been my privilege to this
semester to teach the Frankie seminar
with Professor hazel Carvey on race and
caste and it's been delightful to have
Ilona katsu here with us today we've
already met with her with class and this
is a wonderful experience to have her
interact with us in several venues here
so Ilona is the curator and head of
Latin American art department at the Los
Angeles County Museum of Art she's the
author of numerous publications on Latin
American art and has been responsible
for the installation of the museum's
permanent galleries of Latin American
art no small feat she's been responsible
for major acquisitions of historically
important and modern works from Latin
America and she's created many important
field changing exhibitions and
conferences not just at LACMA but also
in New York City and Mexico City and
other places
she's intrepid in creating in
delineating the field of Mexican and
Spanish colonial art that has its own
specificities rather than being
understood simply as derivative of
Spanish European art she grew up in
Mexico City and that history and her
training in modernist art also has led
her to curate Latin Latino artists as
well she's I here working on a show on
1960s Latin American art and one on
Spanish colonial art which will be very
exciting she is one of the world's
leading authorities on Costa painting
the author of custo painting images of
race in eighteenth-century Mexico and
this constipating is what she will talk
about today examining how concepts of
the Casta came to emerge in Mexico and
very specific social and historical
context and whose meaning and practice
has changed according to shifting
colonial policies that she's written not
just a magisterial book on Costa
painting but also edited
inventing race gossip ending in the 18th
century Mexico and these are and a book
with co-author co-edited with Susan Dean
Smith race and classification the case
of Mexican America that came out in 2009
her mandate of expanding the works in at
LACMA an American art will continue in
many shows and catalogs contested
visions in the Spanish colonial world
painted in Mexico 1700 and set to 1790
Finch Mexico these have all been
groundbreaking including in the shows
the Spanish colonial and Mexican
indigenous artisans who adapted their
work to fit the demands of their new
colonial masters and while cunningly
preserving traditional methods and
motifs we're so fortunate that she could
join us here at Yale her talk today is
entitled they had mention of Casta
painting race and science in the Age of
Enlightenment please join me in
welcoming ataxic hello everybody thank
you so much for joining me here today
it's a great pleasure
I want to thank hazel Carvey and inter
Paula gray wolf for inviting me to the
Institute for having me and said huge
honor and to Salone Baumann for
everything you've done to coordinate the
event which is not a small feat let me
just get settled for a second so this
talk is based on earlier work my first
monograph on Casta painting was in 1996
it was to accompany and exhibition at
the American Society Art Gallery in New
York and it was also the subject of my
dissertation which I turn into a book
published in 2004 that went along with
an exhibition that I organized at the LA
County Museum of Art it's it's a long
journey it's sometimes surprising to me
they're still growing interest in this
area and when I wrote the book I
deliberately tried to not close off
interpretations it's a genre that's
endlessly fascinating complex rich weird
in so many levels and I think that
there's still quite a lot of studies
that can come out from it so I will try
to unpack as much of the information as
I can in 45 minutes one hour which is
very limited amount of time to just go
through everything a lot of things will
probably get left out there will there
might be questions and but I also want
to just keep this at the forefront that
it's a genre that is limitless in terms
of interpretive possibilities and the
complexities and tensions is something
that you will notice hopefully emerge
throughout the talk so I'm gonna just
start by briefly introducing the genre
for some of you who might not be
entirely familiar with it
it's a unique pictorial genre that was
developed in 18th century Mexico what is
remarkable about it is that and this is
the reason why we call it a genre is
that it spanned the entire 18th century
so the first examples really originated
in the first decade of the 18th century
and the last paintings date to around
1810 so we're talking about a really
long time direct the other thing is that
the paintings the corpus of works is
fairly large so we have the paintings
were generally conceived as sets of 16
paintings in separate canvases or copper
plates occasionally you would have the
paintings on a single surface such as
this example by an unknown artist in a
private collection and if you think
about this and you multiply 16 times a
hundred we are really talking about over
2,000 works of art for colonial art for
actually for that matter also for
European art
that is an extraordinary pictorial
output and I always like to sort of keep
that in focus because it's not just a
sidebar of art history this was a very
very popular genre the premise of the
paintings really and we were just
talking about this in the seminar is to
chart the different racial permutations
that took place between the three trunks
or main social groups that inhabited
colonial Mexico that was Native
Americans Spanish colonizers and African
slaves and the paintings tell race they
provide a very specific narrative of
this process of miscegenation by really
keeping spaniards at the top of the
racial scaffolding and blacks at the
bottom there was this notion that
indigenous people because there were
neophytes that were considered pure in
Spanish legislation but the stain of
blackness was considered too huge to be
removed at least in those paintings and
Spanish colonial mentality to a great
extent
so the paintings charred out the
possibilities of returning to a wider
racial poll and that can only happen
between the myth the mixtures between
spaniards and indians that is if you
have for example the three the first
three paintings of most sets depict the
spanish man with an indian woman who
give a mestizo the next painting in the
set would be a mestizo and a spanish man
would give a caste saw and then the
third painting would be a castillo and a
Spaniard who would give back a pure
Spaniard so the idea was to the sort of
what the paintings are promoting is this
idea of going back to a pure Spanish
unadulterated old unadulterated race
which was considered to be the primeval
color of mankind
however the mixture of Indians and
Spaniards with blacks
in this system the sistema de castas
would only lead to racial degeneration
and this is very clearly articulated in
most of the cast office we will see
throughout the the talk also I'm always
very happy to entertain questions in the
middle so if anyone has a comment or a
question please feel free to do that and
I'm just showing you this other example
so you get a sense of the different
formats of the paintings this is one
painting of a set of sixteen by juan
rodriguez wadis where you actually see
the family group in a single canvas now
what's really interesting and this art
to folios from a 1763 manuscript at the
Hispanic Society in New York they have a
great collection they also have Casta
paintings that I was fortunate to
publish a facsimile of the manuscript I
think in 2008 or something and I bring
it here because it just starts to sort
of give you a sense of how some of these
terms were used during the colonial
period so you have this illustration
depicting different racial types and
then you have this very elaborate
taxonomies and this is grant that are
later examples from 1763 but it's kind
of you can see how they're trying to
outline the different types of racial
mixtures and the different types of
names many of the names that were
deployed in the Casta paintings were so
logically inspired terms such as mulatto
and mestizo we're in use with more
neutral senses before the sixteenth
century but by the sixteenth century
they started being used within the
context of Spanish America and
colonization and they started being used
to refer to different types of mixtures
mestizos initially where which is the
mixture of spanish spaniards and indians
was not considered a pejorative type of
mixture but as the century went along it
was it started to be associated
legitimacy and mulattoes was a term that
as we all know derives from mules and it
has to do with the hybrid nature of
animals and they got applied especially
to the mixtures of Spanish and people of
African ancestry and then you have a
whole different rage that are completely
inconsistent list of names that were
applied especially to the unions of
Indians and Africans and many of them
were so logically inspired as well such
as Lobo or wolf coyote and then you have
terms such as Alvarez sada which means
white spotted or chummy so which means
that literally translates as a burned
log and the number just goes on and not
and on Sebago for example knee knocked
so it's the the terminology was deployed
and plea to as society became more mixed
in Spanish in the Spanish colonies
Spanish American colonies the terms
started to be used quite widely now the
question here is who was concocting
these terms and much of the scholarship
has argued that the terms come from a
top-down regime that is that Spaniards
and Spanish legislation was imposing
these terms on to the increasingly mixed
societies but the truth is that many of
those terms actually originated in day
to day life by people themselves it's a
very complex matter it's not completely
resolved and there's even new literature
new scholarship that is arguing that the
sistema de castas the names that were
deployed in the sistema de castas
actually come from the bottom up that is
that there were a lot of it's part of
this new wave of scholarship of giving
agency to so call to ball turn people's
and this new wave of scholarship is
arguing that people actually have much
more
see then we give them credit to that is
that they were writing all these
petitions to the Spanish crown trying to
resolve all sorts of matters where they
actually use some of these terms that
the Spanish lawmakers plugged in
literally from this documents generated
by colonial subjects and they use to
shape their own legislation and that's
that's I just wanted to bring this
because it's important to keep in mind
all the different sides of the with
discourse now why was this genre
invented and it has to do in a large
large measure with the fact that once
the colonizers arrived in the new world
there was by necessity racial mixture
Spanish man came with virtually no women
there was massive mixture between
indigenous women Spanish men and African
slaves as a result many Europeans were
starting to describe the populations of
the new world as hopelessly degraded and
the paintings as we will go through in a
minute are in many ways a response to
that overarching claim that was coming
from European centers of knowledge but
this was also a time when the Americas
was discovered of great interest in
people's that were coming from new parts
of the world this expansionism this
reaching to other parts of the globe
that were not known until then just
generated enormous amounts of curiosity
on the part of Europeans and many
travelogues such as this one by cha-cha
rivets Elio started to be generated with
images that became quite stereotypical
of the peoples of different regions of
the world this is this is actually a
really beautiful book I don't know if
some of you are familiar with it but
it's tiny it has all this different kind
of prints so it's it's quite interesting
to look at
so the Casa paintings in a way are
responding to that larger interest on
the part of Europeans about peoples of
the new world now the thing to keep in
mind is that the Casta paintings
produced in Mexico most sets I would say
actually almost all the sets were
produced in Mexico or New Spain there is
one set that we know of that was created
in the Viceroyalty of Peru which was
clearly modeled after the Mexican
examples so that's something to keep in
mind to the earliest extant sets of
Casta paintings that we know often the
corpus keeps getting enlarged as new
paintings it's amazing but there's
constant flood of new paintings I
probably get emails with new paintings
people telling you about new paintings
every two weeks now some I can match the
certain sets but some are are of
entirely new sets which just again it
just kind of makes that notion of the
corpus of work being so enormous but
this is a terrific work by manuel yada
ya know again most of the works were
created by local mexican artists not
european artists and i say that because
sometimes people ask me that and i think
i just take it for granted
manuel ariana is an artist that was very
important between the he works he was
active between the 17th and the 18th
centuries we don't have a lot of
information about him but there's a
dissertation underway in mexico about
this painters which is very exciting
and this is a painting that is in the
denver art museum which they have they
have a wonderful collection of spanish
colonial art and what's different about
this painting and this is a rendition of
a mulatto is that it doesn't include the
family groups in the same portrait so
here you have basically what we would
call a racial type the what i find also
really interesting about this picture is
the inscription which basically says
that this is a rendering of a mulatto in
mexico city the head or capitol of the
new world in the year
17:11 and that's a very telling
inscription because it speaks to the
notion of a sense of local pride now
whether this work and I'm just gonna
show you the set apparently had more
words we don't know how many the work
that you are seeing here on the left
which is a rendering of a mulatto you so
you see the couples are depicted in
separate canvases is lost so all we have
to go by is this all black and white
photograph from the 40s I think points
are fifties
I wish it would surface somewhere so if
anyone has any notion of where it is
please let me know and I find this works
really interesting and I don't know and
it's um it's not something that I wrote
about in my book it's something that
I've been thinking about lately there
was throughout the 17th and the 18th
century there was this there were many
public festivals public festivals for
example to receive incoming viceroys
that took place there were very
ostentatious they took place in the main
plaza of Mexico City and different
groups of people group different groups
different ethnicities were invited to
perform their own identities so they
came dressed as themselves to perform in
front of the UH new incoming by story
and and submit to to their rule and I
wonder sometimes it paid those paintings
from the set by Manuela I yah know that
are so specifically data to 1711 and are
associated with an incoming the first
incoming Viceroy to Mexico might have
been part of that whole notion whether
these paintings were actually invented
to record part of that part of a
festival the garment that you see in the
mullet and we were talking about this
that the paintings try to differentiate
race fennel typically by distinguishing
the figures skin tone allottee but oh
so through their types of clothing and a
lot of women were banned from wearing
the clothes that Spanish women could
wear so there were very strict sartorial
limitations to what peoples of different
groups could wear and as as a way to
circumvent this measure and because then
we have a lot of documentation from my
European travelers who visited Mexico
the women from African background
devised their own type of clothing and
what we see her wearing here is this
very typical type of garment called a
manga which was literally just like a
skirt fitted from the top that was
fastened with this very colorful ribbons
and had very exquisite gold or silver
brooches so this became the type of
garment that is normally associated with
a depiction of Miletus in Casta
paintings part of the same set includes
the stereotypical depiction of what were
referred to as chichi miko indians which
literally translates as heathen indians
inhabitant inhabiting the north part of
ba the Viceroyalty and this are the type
of images that were abundant in all the
maps and all this kind of cartographic
sources describing the different peoples
of the world and if they even made it to
allegorical descriptions of the americas
but again the inscription is really
telling because they point to Parral
which was a area in the north of mexico
which was supposed to be inhabited by
fierce heathen Indians who would scare
Spaniards
to death and this is what you read in a
lot of the descriptions so it's no
surprise that some of the idea that
there's a deliberate attempt to render
the figure with his mouth open to
suggest the shrieks that are often
described in literature that scared
Spaniards and other people away and also
the facials gara fication
but again I have to wonder if this were
depictions that were somehow connected
to a festival ritual there is
documentation that the first paintings
were commissioned by Viceroy Li Nala's
whom you see here on the right from the
very famous painter who wandered Regas
Juarez and this is a self-portrait of
cuando tengas Juarez one of the very
very few self-portraits of the colonial
period in Mexico and we know this
because there was a letter by a cleric
addressed to a scholar whose name was
Hagar de Gordon who at the time was
compiling a whole kind of bibliography
of Mexican writers and the talent of
local intellectuals because the notion
that Mexico was degenerate was spreading
very much in Europe and there were
authors that were claiming that new
world talents would ripen very quickly
and degenerate by the age of 40 so this
incensed many of the local
intelligentsia and this one cleric wrote
to a yachtie year Gordon - please be
careful to make sure not to mention that
the entire population of New Spain was
hybrid and degenerate because it was a
notion that was greatly tarnishing local
Creole talents so this is how we know
that at least if not the earliest among
the earliest paintings were commissioned
by Viceroy Leonidas wonder the biggest
White has created two sets of Casta
paintings one which surfaced in Bremer
ham Shire in England and here I'm
showing you one example and the other
ones surfaced in a private collection in
Mexico so again this is a different type
of format where you actually see the
individual parents in a single
composition
what's so extraordinary about this
earlier works and I and I think there's
a real change between words that were
created in the first half of the 18th
century and works that were produced in
the second half of the 18th century that
works from the first half are imbued
with this very strong sense of local
pride you see all the different racial
combinations that artists and their
patrons were trying to chart out but
they're all very lavishly dressed even
though they're differentiated through
their skin tone ality and their clothing
there's a sense of pride in this
pictures the only reason if you were not
even paying attention to the inscription
that you can see on the on the top
really outlining the type of racial
combination one would almost feel
inclined to think of this as a European
painting of a family group it's a placid
family portrait and here you see of
course a Spanish man wearing this
typical French three-piece suit with his
wig and the indigenous woman wearing a
type of dress which was or blouse I was
called a whip in which it was a night
native blouse so you're also seeing
again sartorial emphasis to
differentiate the different mixtures I'm
showing you here two other paintings
from the set and again on the left you
can now distinguish see what type of
clothing the mulatta is wearing which is
the manga and the Spanish man is wearing
the cat the cape and the broad hat which
were only worn ah by Spanish man we saw
this work this is a painting from the
second set of hundred riga sweaters in
Mexico City and again you see here the
combination of a Castillo and a Spaniard
who give back a Spanish woman and the
man again wearing the broad hat the Cape
and holding a sword which was the
privilege that was only
granted to people of Spanish blood so
there are all these little details that
really kind of help construct this image
of racial hierarchy it's another
painting from the same set and the one
here on the Left I always like to point
this out because you're seeing sort of
the different mixtures now between
Indians and blacks but yet you still see
them wearing lavish clothing for the
most and in this case you even see the
little child holding up a hat full of
pears which was a European type of fruit
so the message could be that the new
world was so fertile that it was even
able to produce fruits of European
origin so they're always very sort of
like cute symbolism to the pictures
after wander the I guess what is the
main painter of castas was a man by the
name Jose de vara who happened to be a
mulatto painter and he was also an
apprentice to quadriga Suarez so he's
taking up the pictures of his
predecessor but he's doing something
radically different here which is to
portray them full length and provide a
little bit more information about locale
those three paintings I'm showing them
to you because we just discovered them a
couple of years ago they they hadn't
been published we showed them at this
exhibition we recently organized that
called painted in Mexico there are three
really terrific works are in private
collection in Madrid we were just really
excited to be able to find them
and what I want to notice here too
what's very much different in this
paintings is that you're now seeing the
sort of the figures from all these
different angles you're even seeing them
from the back which could be considered
quite indecorous but it's a way to sort
of provide a bigger glimpse into the
types of clothing and also to endow the
compositions with a bigger
of naturalism and make them more dynamic
so Jose Deborah in many ways was trying
to one-up his master one or the u.s.
widest to this niche set the possible
sources for this works might have been
this book by a Attanasio skier share of
cochina monumentous which was a book
that was widely known in Mexico that had
all these different types and we it's
it's because the thing is most Spanish
colonial art most Mexican art at the
time was religious and one has to wonder
where were artists getting their
inspiration to create this very unusual
unique secular genre when they had
really no models to to emulate for it so
the degree of invention is
extraordinarily high and this could be
one potential source that we know was
widely known in Mexico that the artists
and/or their patrons may have been
looking at I'm pointing out this detail
because the emphasis on the clothing is
so acute that you almost have to see
this in the flesh but the artists not
only try to give you a sense of the
different types of quotes that the
figures were but in this case even in
size the paint to give a sense of the
texture so the lines that you see there
are fully incised and the other element
that I want to point out is again the
inscription the inscription here is
barely perceptible so if it were not for
the inscriptions you would really think
of this as placid images of colonial
society and they're not numbered so so
there's really how you arranged all
these different combinations could be
quite haphazard the caster's painting
are very much associated to with the
fascination with the traditions of local
peoples and concurrently there were
paintings such as this describing indian
weddings and indian burials this are
attributed to quand rodriguez Juarez
and what is really interesting again is
that in the especially in the image of
the Indian wedding is that you see the
Indian couple flanked by their Spanish
godparents so this image is in many way
are providing a view of society which is
regimented hierarchical but bound by
love and this notion of creating an
image of a multiracial society that's
fully civilized organized and bound by
love is a key notion of not only Casta
paintings but this related genres and
this is another really wonderful work by
juan rodriguez whiteis of an indian
wedding where you can see even that more
explicitly the couple the Indian couple
is flanked by the Spanish parents each
wearing their appropriate clothing the
Dome of the church is seen in the back
and the indigenous festival is taking
place in great my new detail on the
right side of the composition this is a
work by Jose de Bustos an artist of whom
we virtually know nothing there is a
complete set of his works in a private
collection in Paris and I bring it
because the idea of marriage is really
rendered explicit in this example you
have the wedding band so what this is
telling us and it's a powerful symbol is
that this inter mixtures this unions are
not illegitimate they are what we're
seeing release the sacrament of marriage
so we're seeing a fully Christianized
civilized view of a mixed colonial
society and that's an important thing to
keep in mind when also knowing that the
painters and the people who commissioned
these paintings were probably there were
all local people the local elite Spanish
and Creole elites and by Creole I mean
Spaniards born in the Americas another
possible source for this paintings which
I just love to mention are this car
tohsaka couturiers made aliyah
were letters created in Spain and this
one dates from the 17th century where
families are petitioning to their noble
status and it's a link that hadn't been
done previously in the literature but
many of this books you can see here how
they were so very luxuriously bound and
trying to sort of trace their ancestry
as all Christians and included this very
detailed family portraits might have
been another source of inspiration for
the Casta paintings now what happens
after 1760 with two artists in specific
Juan Patricio more letter with and
Miguel Cabrera is that we see a big
shift happening in the cast of genre we
have many more elements being included
in the compositions and what do we see
here we see that the paintings start to
be numbered so if before all the
paintings were placed almost if you will
equal footing and you could
theoretically hang them in every way you
want it by the second half of the 18th
century you start to see that there's a
much more emphatic emphasis there's more
emphasis on the hierarchy of this works
and instead of presenting a coherent
vision of who goes at the top and who's
at the bottom and this in many ways has
to do with the introduction of the
Borbon reforms at that time when the
Spanish monarchs charge the third
insurance afford specifically we're
trying to rein in the power their power
in the colonies the colonies have become
to a large extent self-sufficient the
Spanish monarchy was losing revenue and
there were very anxious about losing
control of their subjects so the
paintings in a tangential way start
responding to to this emphasis on
demarcating hierarchy but they are also
kind of more connected at
point with the enlightenment and this
widespread notion in Europe of creating
taxonomies and systems of classification
so it's when you also start seeing a
bigger deployment of local fruits and
local fruits and flora and fauna even
and you start seeing more of an
association of people with local types
of abundance and this is another really
extraordinary painting by Huang
potassium or let the reefs of this
marketplace that was close to the
Cathedral called plaza Boulevard where
you can again see that this notion of
abundance and of like equating people
with local products proliferation at the
larger level is it's becoming very much
is coming to the fore in many ways this
is even more emphatic in this later
painting which is practically unknown
it's a painting that just got acquired
by the New Orleans Museum
it's surfaced in the market about a
couple of years ago where you really see
the how different types of peoples and
races are placed at the same level of
the natural world natural bounty of the
colonies and I wanted to bring those two
paintings which are not Casta paintings
proper there are images that were
created in the Viceroyalty of they were
created in Ecuador these are two
paintings that we acquired at my museum
not too long ago where you can again see
this notion of by uniting different
racial types with this enormous
proliferation of local bounty and again
it's we can choose to see this paintings
as deeply related to the Enlightenment
to the nails to notions of taxonomy
classification of flora and fauna
but I would also suggest that this
paintings that are emphasizing the hyper
abundance of the colony is a response to
notions that were circulating in Europe
the generation of native peoples fruits
and vegetables in the new world for
example there was this kind of
expression that was circulating in
Europe that describes the people of the
new world as good cults but bad horses
and which was kind of terrible but the
idea was that people in the new world
were very smart up to the age of 40 and
then they really just started losing
their wits and they applied the same
notion to fruits they said that fruits
were all very beautiful and big and
luscious but once you open them there
were deprived of flavor or substance so
I think that in many ways this kind of
works our response to those notions that
are coming from Europe and in the sense
it's also good to keep in mind that
colonial peoples were very much attuned
to what was happening in the Metropole
and there's this very fluid back and
forth between both centers of both
centers and here you can see you know
that the emphasis on the exterior and
the interior fruits is very much
connected to Enlightenment projects and
here's a typical image that was drawn as
part of one of the famous expeditions of
the period by mu T's in the Viceroyalty
of New Granada where the Spanish
government had actually sent a whole
bunch of people to classify and document
the natural resources of the colony
because they were really trying to rein
in all the revenue that they could
derive from the from colonial context so
the sets by the paintings by Vicente
Alban that I was just showing to you are
in a way they also have been tied to the
expedition of mootisse but this is just
to give you a sense how this notion of
fruit the super abundance of fruit and
natural resources in the new world was
really an old trope this is a 17th
century source
another thing that starts happening
after 1760 is that you start getting
hints of different locations and I'm
pointing out a ridge here which is
directly connected to this major outing
in Mexico City that was known as Paseo
least a calico which was a place that
was famous was described often as a
second Venice it was a place where all
these lakes kind of filled with lakes
and were people of all different
backgrounds it was one of those places
where people from all different
backgrounds were able to convert so it
was widely described in the literature
of the time and by travelers etc and
it's really kind of amazing how a little
bridge that would seem almost nothing to
any viewer really carried deep meanings
and it would have been very well
understood and known by contemporary
viewers now also from like the mid 18th
century we have this kind of like
different type of Casta painting this is
a very unusual one by lucemon an artist
of whom we practically know nothing
where the sense of local pride is even
more so emphatic the original y la Lupe
was had just been named patroness of
Mexico in 1746
so she's presiding over all the racial
permutations all the different gustas of
the colony and to the right you have a
vignette of the Paseo de esta calico and
to the left the century of the original
while I Lupe how would I find really
fascinating about this painting is that
whereas most of the paintings start with
a combination of a Spanish man and an
Indian woman here you not only have that
the dominating race is a Spanish woman
but that the Indian man in this union is
actually a hidden Indian or a Maiko it's
one of those stereotype with the
stereotypical renditions of by
indigenous people so we can't totally
take all the paintings here
really like some of the colonial artists
in my opinion just as there was
satirical literature dealing with the
subject I really poking fun of the
system and that's there's some of these
paintings are really humorous and they
also vary in quality so it's it's
another it's one of those aspects of the
genre that hasn't really been dealt with
very explicitly but the element of humor
and those paintings can also be quite
quite significant now the probably the
most famous set of the entire genre is
is set by Miguel Cabrera who was the
most prominent painter of the 18th
century the set originally had 16
paintings when we took this picture
which was about 8 or 9 years ago only 14
paintings were known LACMA acquired this
painting about three years ago I'm very
happy about this it was discovered
rolled up under a couch so was that her
two paintings missing and this was just
sitting in a house in Northern
California and I'll just give you a
little behind the scene the owner just
reached out and is like I have this
painting under the couch it's like I see
some stuff in Google I think it's
important so we were really lucky and we
were able to acquire it for the museum
and then that meant that meant that only
another painting from the set was
missing so after we acquired this work
we did a whole thing in the LA Times as
though there was a art critic who got
really excited about it
and first page of the paper under the
line I was like a hole to do and where I
had commiserated bitterly that there was
still one missing painting so about a
few months later I got an anonymous
letter signed Espanola because this is
Spanish and Casti Spagnuolo
no return address no nothing saying I
just wanted to let you know that I am
NOT missing I just do not wish to be
found and I'm leaving three miles away
from your Museum
here's a photo of me so you can get a
sense of what I look like and it broke
my heart there was no way to track this
I waited I thought well it this lady or
gentleman who sent me this information
is trying to tease me I'm sure she's
gonna reach out again because she must
know that I really would like to have
his painting the collection her to show
it and then I waited about two years
three years nothing happened we
organized last year our big painting in
Mexico exhibition that took place at the
Met and I was so hoping we could include
that painting in the show but this
person just disappeared and I just
decided to go public with it so we did
this we got the LA art critic and I told
him the whole story he was riveted they
gave it the front page lost painting in
LA blah blah blah we even put a note in
the galleries and the painting I'm still
not surfaced so it's a very sad story up
to this point I'm still waiting but I
just want to go back to this paintings
this are you see very very clearly the
change that's happening with Miguel
Cabrera's painting and the painting of
the Spaniard and the Indian who give a
mestizo there's a this foreshortening of
the Spanish male is really really
something else because you cannot even
see the face of the Spaniard the center
of attention the focus here is the
indigenous woman their child is looking
up adoringly to the couple and many of
these images you must kind of associate
them with religious paintings of the
Virgin and st. Joseph but they're
completely secularized you see the
depiction of the pineapple which was
another type of fruit that was typical
of a new world
the back you see the stall in a market
call el Parian which was the main market
place at the time with this assortment
of local textiles inscribed the word
with a word she looked a baker which was
a type of skirt worn by indigenous women
but truly what's most notable is the
emphasis on the Indian woman and I don't
really know I'd like to read biography
so much into art and we don't Miguel
Cabrera was perhaps the most famous
painter of the 18th century in Mexico
who was probably of indigenous
background or mixed background we really
don't know but by the time he became
very famous in the 1750s he started to
self-described as a Spaniard so that's
another thing that artists were doing
all the time
if to be able to elevate their own
profession as painters they had to
distance it from the castas they
allegedly were not accepting people of
mixed background into their to their
academies or their guilt and to to extol
their own place and the nobility of
painting they would often this
self-described Spaniards yet and this is
again why I say that there's sometimes
an element of trickery to his paintings
of covert tacit messages the fact that
he's so clearly emphasizing the
indigenous woman one cannot help to
think about the sort of this more covert
messages that were taking place in the
genre and the painting on the right it's
the same it's kind of the same notion of
the couple standing against their stall
at the paddy and selling shoes again
with like an assortment of typical fruit
and here I'm just showing you another
image of competition or let there is
where you can actually see the big
structure that was a marketplace the
partying in Mexico city's main square or
Plaza my yard so just going from the
outside to the inside here other two
paintings from the set by Cabrera
and doing our seminar it was really
interesting because some of you I think
hazel and some of the students - you
were pointing out and I just thought
this was a really cool observation that
the paintings are kind of characterized
by a certain degree of intimacy so this
notion of being a family unit of being
bound by love is very present but it's
only the parents touching the children
there's no connection between the
parents themselves and that's something
that does recur in a lot of the
paintings and it also begs the question
as to why is that - other paintings from
the series of covet and what I wanted to
show here is that clothing start to be
using also at this stage to introduce a
notion of class so whereas in the
earlier part of the century everybody
regardless of their racial makeup was
dressed in the most ostentatious of
clothes by the second half of the 18th
century you start seeing people of lower
classes of lower racists racial
combinations associated with class so
you start seeing figures that are
wearing tattered clothing for example
truthfully the genre explodes by 1770
after 1770 there is the bulk of the
paintings were created some signed by
artists who are known and most of them
by anonymous artists which tells us that
there was an increasing demand for this
works which were probably was probably
connected to the spread of cabinets of
natural history in Europe people who
were coming to the new world such as
viceroys and other ambassadors who came
for short periods of time and then they
wanted to go back to Europe with a
souvenir of their stay two of their
stays in the colony and what we see here
this is a set by and raises less
happened to be an apprentice of Miguel
Cabrera also there's very little work by
him but for some reason we have to cast
a sets full cast a set signed by him you
start seeing that whenever you see a
Spanish man the family groups are
situated in such a way that you
essentially in themes of leisure so
they're either performing music or you
can see that they're literate other
family groups include the playing of
cards for example in a contrived setting
and I bring this one too because during
the Borbon before into the Spanish
monarchy was really trying to control
revenue and playing cards was a royal
monopoly and there's a lot of
descriptions of how playing of cards was
causing great trouble in the colony was
creating great unrest but yet the Casta
paintings always show them with a
Spaniard and in a very contrived setting
and the famous images of nursing this
was a time these are some of the most
difficult images in a way because the
the literature talks a lot about the
problems with using wet nurses it was
wet nurses of indigenous or African
background because it was this whole
notion that the children would imbibe
the bad vices with a milk of their wet
nurses so at this time and it was a very
Servite spread discourse at the time so
what you see a crying during this decade
is showing family groups where the
Spanish man is overseeing the nursing of
their wives for the most so it's it's
the message was very powerful and just
in case you didn't know that color was
not enough sartorial emphasis clothings
was not enough now you start seeing
moral attributes subscribe to the
different types of mixtures so the
mixtures of Spaniards and blacks which
was seen as the most
the one with the most potential to
corrupt the whole system you actually
see scenes of violence and so the this
kind of scene which is recurrent in
paintings after 1770 are really
admonishing vignettes telling people
what the improper or the less desirable
type of mixture would be and I'm just
showing you some other so you can see
that how prevalent the scene was and the
other thing that you see happening at
this time is again the emphasis on
trades because if we think of the
paintings in connection to the Borbon
reforms this whole notion of deriving
larger revenue for the Spanish crown
becomes really imperative at this time
okay so that is basically an overview of
the paintings I'm gonna just show you
very quickly to wrap it up the category
of all vinyls if somebody in the class
was asking and I didn't want to give too
much in but albinos became they start up
hearing since the early paintings in the
early part of the 18th century but it
became one of those categories that
became much more prevalent in the second
half of the 18th century and here you're
seeing again the LA County Museum
painting on your your left they're both
from Miguel Cabrera and they're really
interesting because the children are
whiter than white so you didn't have an
inscription you would almost take this
to be a Spanish child but there was a
virtual obsession with the albino
category at this time and it was also it
was also a racial category that was
being widely debated in European circles
mostly because they didn't know what to
do with it they didn't know how to fix
it albinos in European circles by some
intellectuals were discussing them as a
different race all together and if a
species that could not propagate and
that's a really key thing albinos could
not propagate but another kind of line
of this
course was that a vinyls were born
mainly to people of African descent and
that they exemplified the return to the
the return to the so-called primeval
white color of mankind so it was it was
in connection to that whole concept
people really didn't have a sort of a
language of genetics to to discuss these
things and they were really obsessed
with this category so in the painting of
espanol and Alvina torna trois you have
this couple with a darker child torna
trois literally meaning return backwards
so it's the idea that albinos although
white they descended from people of
African origin and their children would
return with jump backwords in the racial
scaffolding they would keep moving
towards blackness as opposed to
whiteness this is a really incredible
painting that tells the story so well by
an artist whose name was Caesarea see
right it also just recently surfaced in
the market and you see the two parents
ostensibly white and the mom is the
mother is nursing this very dark child
and then on top of that you have the
woman in the back who's pulling up her
glasses to verify that what she's seeing
is actly correct how could two white
parents be get a darker child so those
are the kind of kind of inner jokes if
you will of the paintings like they are
laden with the sense of humor but they
were also very telling in regards to
sort of like more ample discussions that
were taking place across the Atlantic
they're really espousing the idea that
vinyls are not sterile as some people
claimed as they're incorporating them
into this entire web of social mixtures
there was also the notion that albinos
could not see that they their vision was
very poor and they were very feeble and
here you see this very unique scene that
also recently surfaced in the market
where the child is kept in a dark room
and you can tell that because there is a
candle in the back and the ambivalence
of the scene is quite remarkable because
you have this that the man at the door
ostensibly the parent giving a coin to
the older woman and you don't really
know if he's in the sort of the
domesticity is very confusing because
you're not sure whether he's providing
money to support his child or if he's
paying money to see this freak of nature
as they were often referred so I'm gonna
close there and yeah I'm just gonna sort
of finish there because it's been an
hour and and I'm open to questions it is
a very broad overview and we just have
to do it in 45 minutes that I hope it
touched it many of the issues that the
paintings raised
[Applause]
yes Larry which is throwback yes
[Music]
[Music]
familiar are you aware that there might
have been a similar genre and other
colonial outposts in the world
French outpost Dutch outposts or is this
specific to the Spanish it's very
specific to the Spanish to the Iberian
world that's what makes the genre so
unique and in fact you have people like
Edward Leung who was described who wrote
a book about Jamaica who I mean this was
the this paintings must have been so
popular that even here as a passing note
in his book about Jamaica about how the
Spaniards had invented all this Casta
terms and that they kind of made it us
made it into a science
so there's yeah but it's it's a very
it's just very typical of the Iberian
world there are other depictions of
different ways of portraying racial
bodies in other parts of the world but
not exactly through this metaphor of the
family group and the successive
generations yes
yes yes so in the spirit of the code
file what you stated at the outset got
the multiple possible interpretations of
an image of this time I'm curious to
know if there were there was a discourse
in Mexico in the 18th or 17th century
that might look at this image and
suggest what what this is really telling
us is that the the Spaniard is not the
father of the child ah well and my other
question is in connection with that was
there a discourse in Spain that was
transmitted to Mexico about who and what
is a Spaniard since after all as you
said this pattern is being held up as
the pure but surely there was I took
that just in response to the first one
there was this obviously some of the
painters were really keen on emphasizing
this knowledge of men this this concept
of marriage right was showing that these
are not illegitimate unions but when you
see paintings like this specifically and
this is where you have like the older
woman just kind of looking kind of like
why does this you you you wonder and
this is why I think it's much better to
leave some of these questions open and
and pose them but we you know how they
were interpreted in their own day is
it's a very difficult thing to approach
so we we're bringing our own baggage of
knowledge and it's weird this is very
largely inferential world and even I
imagine that even back in the 18th
century people who would have seen the
same image would have come out with
different interpretations it's just
human nature as to the your question
about the Spaniards
it's really interesting because there
was this notion of rasa in Spain that
was in this concept of grass our race
that was used in Spain in the medieval
period to distinguish between Nobles and
prevalence or Pateros tax payers and in
the 1500s it was it started to be used
not so much to distinguish between
nobles and and taxpayers but more
between all Christians and new
Christians there was this whole
phenomena of comparisons at the time
Jewish converting to Christianity and
with it came great deal of skepticism
about the truthfulness of this
conversions and we have to remember that
this coincided with the rise of
Protestantism with the encroachment of
the Ottoman Empire with the Counter
Reformation so the Spanish the Spanish
monarchy was living through a great
period of instability and utter anxiety
and to be able to preserve the
prerogative of noble Spaniards there
started labeling on the concept of race
to religion so there was this notion
that to become a full fully integrated
old Christian you have to wait three or
four generations and this had very real
repercussions in practical life because
to be able to be accepted into the
church or other institutions that
demanded proof of your psi the sangria
purity of blood there were like massive
massive questionnaires where people
would just go out and interview
everybody they know to find out if a
certain individual really went back
three or four generations and they could
be considered all Christians so what I
find really interesting is that this
religious notion of all Christian versus
new Christian when the
[Music]
encounter with the Spanish colonies
occurs they're sort of labeling that
system on to the races so in other words
you have the system is being secularized
so now it's not that you need three or
four generations to become an old
Christian is that you need three
generations to become a pure Spaniard so
those yeah those are those those are
really great questions anyone else yeah
so it was that more about
or was it referring to but I'm not
surprised because caste cells were just
one step away from being a Spaniard so
it's it would make sense and again
there's I think because this paintings
are so well charted we ourselves have
that need almost to kind of understand
things in a very strict way but the
paintings are are all over the place the
the vignettes are all over the place so
just when you think you have it right
there's a painting like men at where you
see the Indian sort of the Indian
heathen Indian marrying the Spanish
woman so it's like yeah yeah like where
they display yes the I wish we had more
information but the we do know that the
paintings some of the paintings were
taken back to Spain and they were they
were displayed in cabinets of natural
history we know for example of a famous
bishop in Mexico Lawrence Ana who went
back to Toledo and he created his Museum
of cabinets of curiosity and he had some
paintings that he exhibited there there
any number of cabinets of natural
curiosities throughout Europe that had
this painting so I think many of them
were produced for that context others
some others were just collected by
people who came to the new world took
them back and they were probably in
their polenta and in their palaces or
their houses but we don't have a lot of
concrete information I mean we I haven't
encountered a single description of
where this paintings how they were
displayed or how they ordered them no I
just recently found a newspaper clipping
and which is from the
it's from the 19th century actually of a
sale in one of the auction houses in
London where they're actually
publicizing the sale of this amazing
paintings by Marino of all things and
it's a big page about this famous
painting by Maria that's being sold in
bond and then at the very bottom and we
have this fascinating series by Cabrera
of Casta paintings also beyond blah blah
blah so this that came from the family
of a very notorious aristocrat in Spain
but they're very this is there just a
spattering of references yeah yes but
you know why this seems very uniquely
mess
why isn't it for the learners runner in
Kiruna process any office yeah that's it
that's a it's also a really wonderful
question and really hard to answer
it's uh the chicken or the egg in part I
think you know it's I think it's but if
my Andy and his colleagues heard me they
would kill me so I don't think I should
say this I think there was a much deeper
and I'm a much more deeply entrenched
pictorial tradition in Mexico that there
was in other parts of the Viceroyalty
and Mexico was a real center of power at
that time with a very sort of organized
group of intelligentsia and if this
paintings were created at least
initially as a reaction to the criticism
of hybridity in the new world I could
see why they were created there the only
reason there is a Peruvian painting is
because there was a huge amount of
travel back and forth between people in
Mexico and Peru and I'm pretty positive
that somebody from Mexico traveled to
Peru and just mentioned you know how or
even brought with them a pair set of
Casta paintings and Chris dovell usana
who was the most prominent painter of
the time was commissioned to paint it by
the viceroy of the time and that's but
that's it that's just someone one off
but I really it's a great question it's
epistemologically I think I just I just
can't answer
yeah 18 very equally an Austrian wrote a
thesis about the opportunity to write
Brazil religion history and he proposed
the idea of fighting three generations
too
but the demographic the demographic was
that time where the eighty percent of
the population in Rio was black then it
was a kind of optimistic Oh ideal then
I'm worrying about the represent like
this gap between the representation of
phenotypes and the depth the demography
of these groups and second question is
about this Dutch painter of the occult
who painted some casts from Brazil the
man who goes and like many groups and if
there's a circulation of his work in
Mexico like to inspire this kind of yes
yeah yeah the commissioned by NASA right
yes I I see your point
I don't think there was a connection
between account and the Mexican
paintings I think you know there was as
I was trying to point out with the
travel books it was a virtual obsession
with trying to understand what people
across the globe looked like I mean we
have to remember there was no television
there was nothing like no Netflix
nothing so the way to gain some
knowledge was through paintings and
books is so different places documented
the diversity of the population in
different ways but I don't really see a
connection between the beautiful account
paintings and the Dutch colonies and the
Mexican ones there is in the sense that
they were all so obsessed with
documenting images of albinos and that's
that was that was just very much in the
air across the Atlantic
timing was a really hotly debated topic
in the period did I answer and did I
answer everything okay
anyone else okay well thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]